when you make a mistake in business you
have to make it right you cannot let
your customers walk away unhappy hi I'm
Evan Carmichael and I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and I
recently made a pretty big mistake I put
on a webinar I promoted it for a month I
had some partners promoted I create a
lot of content for it was going to be
great being of the webinar comes people
are signing in but they can't get access
to it somewhere along the line we had a
definitely technical difficulty that we
couldn't figure out on the spot and so a
lot of people were disappointed you have
to make it right so I wrote to the
people who signed up and what I gave
them was access to the next webinar
we're going to put on a free copy of one
of my worksheets and an offer for a free
30 minute private one-on-one coaching
with me and that was for a free webinar
and it's a lot more work for me to do
that to recognize those people but it's
on me my company made that mistake and
so it's on me to fix it you do not want
people walking away from an experience
with your business being unhappy word of
mouth is so important for a company
especially small companies because we
don't have the big money to spend on
advertising campaigns and hiring
marketing companies most of time is on
us it's on you personally for your small
team you need to have positive
word-of-mouth you need people going out
there talking about how great an
experience I had with your business you
cannot let people walk away from your
company unhappy and quite often if you
can solve a problem you can turn in a
disgruntled prospect into a happy loyal
customer if you go above and beyond to
make them happy they'll forget about
that first experience and say what a
great company this is and they'll tell
people that
they started off with something negative
and you turned it around for them and
how much they loved the service at your
company you have to make sure people
love working with you mistakes are going
to happen as part of business you try to
avoid as much as possible you're still
going to make mistakes along the way
what's important is how you deal with
those mistakes how you handle it and try
to build into your system the notion
that people must not walk away unhappy
after doing business with you I hope you
apply to your company good luck for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below I
love seeing those come in and I'd also
love to hear we have to think about this
video or if you have a question about
your own company leave it in the
comments section below I always read
those love seeing them come in thank you
so much and I'll see you on the next
episode
you